on a tributary of the Han River South
Korean engineers and their U.S
counterparts carefully float sections of
a pontoon Bridge into position ready for
a river crossing a vital skill they say
in time of War
ner considering the number of rivers on
the Korean Peninsula it's crucial to
have this capability it could decide a
success or failure of a wartime
operation
large joint exercises have been scaled
back in recent years to help attempts at
dialogue with North Korea over
denuclearization
with those talks failed it seems a
different type of bridge building now
takes precedence the main message that
we're trying to send is just to show
that we are stronger together and that
we will continue to work to strengthen
our alliance and our capabilities the
Allies deny these exercises are
provocative
the resumption of large-scale exercises
between U.S and South Korean forces
serves they say as a deterrent in the
face of renewed threats from North Korea
but Pyongyang uses these same drills as
justification for its unprecedented
worry of missile tests multiple missile
tests have been carried out since the
start of the year with the north
declaring itself a nuclear-armed state
and intent on developing an arsenal of
smaller tactical nuclear weapons it
fired an intermediate range missile over
the top of Japan for the first time in
five years that came after joint Naval
drills involving a U.S aircraft carrier
for the first time since 2017. joint Air
Force drills planned for the end of this
month will involve scores of U.S and
South Korean war planes a build up in
military activity the length of the
Korean Peninsula increasing the chances
for a miscalculation or mistake that
could have Untold consequences Rod
McBride Al Jazeera yoju City South Korea